the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
you
sometimes psychologists like to talk
about two aspects of remind of hot and
the cool okay
so the cool parts we've been talking
about recently thinking parts like
language thought things related to
intelligence problem-solving
you know the rational aspects of the
human mind and today we're going to
focus on you know maybe the hottest of
the hot the emotions that we feel and
that you know sort of color our lives in
terms of intensity and arousal and what
matters to us and so we'll talk a little
bit about just very briefly about a
thumbnail history of the study of
emotion the scientific study of emotion
ideas about how to define it a few
models of emotion how emotion might work
some big questions about things are is
emotion universal the correlate to a
bodily feelings why do we have a motion
and then things about the brain basis of
emotions so we have a huge number of
words by one count you know about 550
words that describe the feelings we have
the emotions we have and we have so you
know there's a lot of overlap
conceptually among them but we have so
many words because we think that we feel
that from our daily lives the feelings
and emotions that we have are such a big
part of our human existence right how we
relate to other people we feel when
we're by ourselves the motions are just
a big big part of how we go about our
lives and they're readily apparent to us
everywhere we look on the faces of
others a positive emotions negative
emotions fearful emotions you see them
around you all the time
so in psychology a lot of sort of ideas
about formulating the field go back to
William James who worked at Harvard who
articulated in many ways in language
that's still relevant to this day the
basic ideas the basic things about being
a human that one wants to understand out
of a psychology and as he wrote about
emotion this way if you can conceive of
yourself suddenly stripped of all the
emotion with which our world now
inspires you know one portion of the
universe would have more important
characteristics beyond another and the
whole character of its things in series
and events would be without significance
character
prescient perspective right that what we
fear what we desire what we enjoy all
what we find disgusting we'll talk a
little bit about discuss today that all
those things you know tell us what's
important and whether it's to be avoided
or approached enjoyed or loathe and so
you know people have thought about
emotions uh you could pick a million
different cultural directions here's a
picture from a Greek philosophy but you
could pick practically every culture
around the world you can't right be a
human and not think about the feelings
you have but kind of strikingly in terms
of research for a very very long time
compared to language or thinking or many
topics people sort of didn't study
emotion because it seemed hard to study
scientifically and it's still harder to
study scientifically in many ways I
think than cognition but there's been
tremendous progress in bringing
scientific approaches to understanding
something about emotions in you and I
and you know like many things was
reinvigorated around the Renaissance and
the mystery of Mona Lisa's smile and now
there's entire journals and conferences
and organizations of scientific
psychology devoted to study emotion it's
a big part of our lives you would think
in the study of the human mind and brain
and be a big endeavor and it is now but
that wouldn't have been true even 20
years ago so how am i we define emotion
just to sort of have some boundaries so
we could say that emotions are
biologically based responses to
situations that are seen as personally
relevant they are shaped by learning and
usually involve changes in peripheral
physiology you know your hands are
trembling or things like that your heart
is pounding expressive behavior how the
intonation with which you speak
the facial expression that you have or
see in others and subjective experience
you know the emotions you have go with
what you feel is going on inside you
researchers try to distinguish between
moods and emotions and talk about moods
as diffuse long-lasting emotional states
you know when you're in a funk or a
positive mood over you know days weeks
months that's not what we're going to
talk about today that's interesting and
important also we're going to talk about
emotions which are very punctate
immediate responses to situations to a
specific thing or specific stress or
specific element of your environment an
immediate strong response and within
that one more distinction has turned out
to be useful for thinking about emotions
between two dimensions arousal or you
called intensity and valence so arousal
means things that are exciting and tense
if they're high arousal or calm or
lethargic if they're low arousal valence
refers to whether it's a positive thing
that makes you elated or contented
negative sadder groomy and you can
already see for example they take
positive valence elated as high arousal
right contented ah that's lower
resolution
they're both positive but they're kind
of difference so it's calm versus
lethargic being calm can be sometimes
good feeling really slow really
lethargic right also it's low arousal
but it's usually not a desirable low
arousal and so people think that they
can take basically there's two
dimensions valence and arousal and use
it as a useful way to say something like
calm is here it's just a little bit
positive and it's low on the arousal
dimension excited is up here it's
positive valence and that different
thing gloomy right is negative and it's
fairly intense feeling as opposed to
merely lethargic so that these two
dimensions can cover a big sense of the
life of emotions that inhabit us at a
huge question and one that's brutally
hard is satisfied some deep scientific
way of course is is it restricted to
humans so if you hang around pets and
animals in various circumstances you
can't help but feel they have emotions
it's just very hard for us to ask them
to fill out questionnaires telling us
the remotion so you know here's a chimp
that has lost its mother recently
there's a dog going out for good all
night here's an armadillo going we right
looks looks pretty aroused and so so you
know we don't know how much of this in
some cases is us reading human feelings
into their expressions how much of that
is them feeling the same as we do
there's a lot of sense that's obviously
that many
species have feelings as well as humans
will focus just on humans today and the
other thing that's important is they're
shaped by learning what that means is
many different things but for example
they can vary in culturals from one
culture to another in certain ways and
here's one example of a you know a movie
that's bringing tears to everybody's
eyes except this person who finds it
utterly hilarious okay all right and if
you work in a motion research I could
tell you you you get that we show I
worked a little bit in that you know you
show some really horrible pictures
everybody horrible horrible horrible it
somebody else think starts laughing
let's say horror movies have you been
around horror movies or some people I
really you know really scared out of
their seats and very worried about the
characters and other people think it's
all pretty funny so that's you know your
perspectives it's not an automatic
response to certain many situations
so how have people thought about you
know the emotion you feel when a bear
jumps out of your closet unexpectedly so
here's the logical one okay common sense
bear is scary right you feel fearful
that's your subjective experience and
your body starts to do things like your
heart starts to pump your sweat glands
starts to sweat because you go this is
dangerous this is scary here comes my
body that would be the intuitive one my
heart is pounding because I feel afraid
interestingly you cannot reverse the
order and find some things that are
better explained that way so this is
it's sometimes nice sometimes people
will say oh my gosh everything in
psychology is so obvious for some reason
they always say my grandmother would
have known it I don't know why they
picked that example you know show us
something that science only can tell you
okay
so here's here's a very clever reversal
from William James and also lang we
reversed it they said that first comes
the bodily response to the situation and
second comes your mind interpreting your
body's primary response the exact
opposite order of why we feel as we do
he's we feel sorry because we cry angry
because we strike afraid because we
tremble and not that we strike cry or
tremble because we are sorry angry or
fearful it's the exact opposite here's
the first comes an emotion that's
shaking your body in some way and then
comes your mind saying aha
I'm afraid you know pretty fast or I'm
happy or whatever so here's some
examples cuz you could think okay
yeah you can cleverly reverse them but
is there any science to suggest that in
some cases that relationship does
reverse so here's where people did I'll
show you a picture over this they said
how can peripheral bodily events things
on sort of the edge of our bodies
influence the emotions we feel inside so
they would have people do things like
hold a pencil tightly between their
teeth and look at that pencil they're
not told to smile they're just told to
keep that pencil there and what does
that look like a smile right okay you've
tricked the person's face into smiling
and they don't even know that
necessarily their thinking is a weird
psychology experiment about how long can
you hold a pencil in your mouth although
they're going to know something more in
a moment
or between the lips hold that pencil now
does this person look happy no a little
bit not happy right okay all right okay
and then you have them watch a funny
movie that most people find funny and
they rate how much they like it and the
person who had this one rakes it as more
enjoyable than the person holding a
pencil this way as if already having the
muscles in your face moved into a
position that typically signals
happiness or laughter makes you feel
happy inside in the funny movie you know
as it is even funnier being in a
somewhat you know neutral to negative
position makes that same funny movie
seem less funny you're interpreting the
fit you know where your muscles are they
normally go with one emotion or another
and that's driving your internal final
emotion about how you feel about the
movie what's your question
well does one require more concentration
so you'd have to work that's an
excellent question
because we always like to say oh it's
this thing you know what if this is a
harder thing like that and so one would
have to hope and I have to admit I don't
know you know that they've controlled
for things like that in some way if you
read the research paper you'd want to
because that's an excellent question you
know if this is just harder work then
maybe you're less paying less attention
to the movie just hanging on to that
pencil I I don't know then I have to
hope they did a good job and that's an
excellent question and here's you know
other ones where again where they're
trying to get the face to go smiley or
go frowny and then they just ask them
how do you feel and this person will say
will write themselves as feeling happier
than this person as they answer on a
piece of paper in front of them again
they're trying to say you know if I can
move your peripheral facial expressions
into the muscles into expressions the
feelings will follow from the
expressions you can also do something
else which is you can tell people so
Paul Ekman his name will come up a lot
of day he's a fantastic amount of the
key research in this making motions into
a research topic in many ways what he
developed is a way that he said I'm
going to describe objectively which
muscles are in which position for each
of six fundamental emotional expressions
we'll come back to those so he you know
he would tell a person raise your
eyebrows and pull them together raise
your upper eyelids now stretch your lips
horizontally back towards your ears so
what he's giving this person
step-by-step these directions that move
the muscles into into an expression of
fear by the time you end up there the
participant usually doesn't know that as
it's so weird okay you're moving your
mouth you move in your it's just so
weird right but then they can do these
kinds of experiments and you know these
people will report a fearful movie as
being more fearful than somebody who
just gets to sit there or has whose
muscles are moved into a happy position
so you know all of a sudden you've got
all these peripheral things being
interpreted by your mind as a signal for
what emotion you have or enhancing it
anyway and then because any strong
theory is usually turns out to be not
nearly complicated enough you get the
wishy-washy middle but probably covers
more of the truth you know which is both
things are going on both you're having a
subjective cognitive
rotational your environment and a bodily
response maybe more in parallel than one
driving the other so again how can
peripheral bodily events influence
emotions so one idea that's floated
around and probably true is that the
perception or thought your your mental
interpretation of your emotion tells you
the type of emotion okay so it's not a
bear jumps out you know you can say okay
I know something's pretty intense and I
can tell you either way it's bad good
alright but if something wonderful jumps
out of your closet unexpectedly then you
know they go oh my gosh I can't believe
you know that Lindsay Lohan is visiting
me and I didn't even know it didn't sure
then I'm if that is considered a good
visit you know that you know that that
that would influence the again the
interpretation but that the intensity
might come from the bodily parts how
intense it is might be signaled from
that so here's a couple of ways that
people explore this so um here's a study
from years ago from a chapter where he
injected people with adrenaline
adrenaline is the neural hormone that
goes with high arousal it raises your
heart rate or a placebo so he's directly
taking the chemical that we normally
produce under higher arousal conditions
and the first question you might ask is
and you might be curious about it if
somebody gave you a shot of adrenaline
you know what would you happen would you
like jump out of your seat and run laps
around the room or what would you do and
surprisingly all by itself not very much
people said they feel a bit jittery like
if you've had maybe a little too much
coffee or Red Bull is out of the current
okay yeah I see that little jittery
feeling but they're not like jumping it
up and you know doing jumping jacks and
one-armed push-ups and stuff like that
they're not having be okay now having
had the placebo or the adrenaline
injected into you and you don't know
that is they just show you an emotion
eliciting they'll show you a movie like
a horror movie and the people that the
adrenaline will feel report more fear
when they see the horror movie more
anger
when they get insulted that's a fun
experiment when you insult them you know
they I'm sure the IRB have to be pretty
careful
more laughter for a comedy so the
adrenaline seemed to amplify the
intensity
of the emotion but the emotion was
driven by the situations that make sense
okay but here's something quite
interesting about humans which is that
if you told them we've given you
adrenaline and it usually amplifies
stuff then it disappeared once the
person knew that they could discount
that in their mind so it's not like
Adrenaline's your master okay and that I
must have a twice as big a response once
you knew that was in the picture and
people the ratings went back to placebo
okay so it's not that biology is destiny
but under normal circumstances it seems
like the adrenaline accentuates the
intensity so that would go with this
possibility that peripheral stuff drives
the intensity peripherally injected
adrenaline and our minds interpretation
drives the content here's a sort of fun
slightly sexist experiment that in the
end I think explains the following
phenomenon when you see famous movie
stars go into movie set on set or
whatever they call it you incredibly
often hear about romances occurring
between the leads right and there's
debates about whether this is just the
press agents selling their movie or
whatever but you hear that all the time
right okay so I'm going to tell you why
that happens when it really happens I
can't really tell you that but I can
tell you a sperm that might touch on
that right so here's the experiment this
was done by Dutton and Aaron in North
Vancouver Canada and they did the
experiment in an area where there were
two bridges not right way connected to
each other pretty near each other one
was a flimsy suspension bridge five feet
wide swaying and wobbling three hundred
and twenty feet over jagged boulders and
river rapids right so you have to
imagine Indiana Jones right okay and
like you come to this bridge and you go
I don't know you know videos okay the
other one upstream same river same
Canadian District there's a steady low
broad bridge no problem at all right you
could drive your car over that no
problem all right two bridges over the
same waters one seeming scary one not
that's what then what they did is in the
middle of each bridge they place an
attractive in this case female
Confederate somebody should maybe
somebody's done the reverse gender
experiment I don't know that is anyway
and as men walk across the bridge they
asked them to fill out a questionnaire
does it you know some boring
questionnaire and they casually
mentioned that if that person
as they finish the questionnaire has
more questions he can call the woman
providing the question at home and she
provides him her home number okay and
the measure that they have is how many
phone calls go from the male subjects to
the female experimenter at home okay
and they're betting that it's not really
scientific curiosity that's driving a
lot of the phone calling all right but
here's what they actually find more
males will call that female at home use
it if they were on the dangerous bridge
than on the safe bridge that's the
actual finding and the interpretation is
this the dangerous bridge because of the
true feeling of danger produces high
arousal increased adrenaline and that's
misinterpreted or what if you want to
call that by the male because he thinks
now he's super attracted to that woman
because of the swaying bridge okay so
another reason to take your if somebody
you want to win over of you know
whatever whatever the gender situation
is you know a really scary roller
coaster ride
you know it's highly recommended
together with that warm beverage as long
as it doesn't spill on there I mean I'm
giving I'm making you too powerful to
control people right but uh you know
that again the arousal of the bridge has
been misinterpreted by that person as as
an intense attraction to that woman and
you could imagine making movies at
probably high arousal exciting
situations and that would promote
romantic relations and in high intense
situations that might not other occur
yeah they had to randomly assign them to
one bridge or the other yeah you would
hope you know you would I can tell you
there's been a bunch of other
experiments sort of like this this is
the most we could call ecological silly
or sexist you could figure interpreters
but it all go with this idea that if
you're in a high arousal situation you
sort of move over that arousal into
whatever seems to be whatever it is
you're in codings that makes sense okay
and in this case because you're creating
an interaction between a man and a woman
it's promoting this probability of a
sense of romance in the male is that
okay but it could be any situation as
the arousal will make it if it's
something bad it can make you feel worse
about it
ah totally excellent question you're
asking awesome questions you know now
this is bigger ah you know I have to
assume and this is I should know this
but I don't that that they weren't yeah
because if you had male self-selecting
you know you huggly some males running
to the dangerous bridge drawn to danger
another saying oh please give me a safe
road okay you know is that the real
difference so you have to presume they
did something to control that yeah the
excellent question but but so the
current view is you know something like
that there's two factors that there's
both there's a bodily response that
happens pretty fast pretty automatically
pretty unconsciously there's a lot of
interpretation and the combination of
that bodily response and an
interpretation leads you finally to the
subjective experience you have and
probably it works differently for
different emotions and things are
complicated as today but the order you
know we're pretty far from this first
guess in terms of the fact that
peripheral things can have very powerful
effects on how you interpret situations
the intensity with which you
interpretations and the intensity itself
can change the behavior that follows the
situation so three questions in the
field are our emotions Universal are
they in you from when you're born are
the same for people around the world do
they have unique physiological
signatures could we define if we knew
your heart rate if we knew your you know
your pulse and so on could we know what
emotional state you're in and then
speculations as to why we have emotions
at all what's the use of having emotions
so brilliant as he is in so many ways in
many ways this dialogue began in modern
times with Charles Darwin who noticed
that animals had very striking facial
expressions as we saw before and that
made him think about the evolution
official expressions there was as one of
his drawings of a cat so here's infants
having early displays of emotions and so
people been very disgust surprise
sadness anger fear so people have in
very impressed that very early on
infants are having the full array of
expressions of course they might see
them you know from moments from their
birth they have people around them but
it's very early
that's almost for sure a really
interesting line of research I'll show
you
Apple has been looking at emotional
expressions emotional facial expressions
in people who are born deaf or born
blind so they never hear intonation they
never see a facial expression right they
can't learn it from their environments
so they're there they're there a sort of
a natural window into ours this inborn
in us or do we learn it from people
around us so here's an experiment where
they took spontaneous facial expressions
of emotion and athletes from both the
Olympics and at Paralympics and they
looked especially it congenitally blind
people with born blind never saw face
and sighted athletes and they looked at
the expressions after winning or losing
an Olympic level match and before I show
you this you may know the story you know
what happens after an Olympic event
somebody wins and where do they go do
they go you know this podium thing the
gold medal winner is up here and the
silver is here and the bronze is here
and they've also done studies this is
just a side note saying who looks the
happiest in those pictures the bronze
medal winner who looks a saddest in
those pictures the silver right because
the bronze medal of winner is going
thank goodness I came in third place
I'm in a podium I have an Olympic medal
if I was fourth place fourth through
infinity gets the same Olympic medal
right okay the silver medalist what's he
or she thinking on average man if I had
just you know one more fractions of a
millisecond I could be the gold medalist
right okay so it's kind of an
interesting thing of you know when we
consider things satisfactory or not but
now let's turn back to this question so
here's two people who just lost Olympic
medal matches and your question is which
is a sighted person which is a blind
person and to the extent it's hard to be
certain that would be a big suggestion
that these expressions are inborn in us
because a person who's never seen a sad
expression still has a sad expression
and the answer is that's the blind
athlete meses itíd athlete so it's
pretty convincing I think that these are
we're born with this set of expressions
as a core entity of being human
even though we're born with that you
know we live in different cultures of
very different cultures around the world
and even within countries and across
countries and so how Universal are these
sorts of things and there's lots of
evidence of a degree of influence of
cultures even with around this core
universality such as a smile meaning
friendship to everyone and again a neck
Minh and is our study made a big study
in which they argue that as far as they
can tell and looking around at facial
expressions there's six basic emotional
expressions that signal feelings
happiness sadness fear anger surprise or
disgust these are all people who are
trained to try to make the perfect
expression of those things okay they
look kind of weird by themselves right
they look kind of weird
you don't see a neutral one here maybe
we'll see a neutral and later neutral is
kind of weird because you go well it's
neutral but I can tell you a totally
neutral face looking at you it can be
kind of creepy right you know because if
you interact with somebody like they
have no expression at all it's a little
disturbing right so because we normally
we're you know but these these these are
ones that are pretty universally
recognized but not completely so let's
take Westerners people from United
States or Europe you know we're not
perfect that even with these posed
pictures this is how often people came
up with the correct labels are you
pretty often not perfect so if there's a
lot of mystery the edges of this but
here's how people came up from
non-western cultures for the same
Western faces well above chance but you
know not the same as Westerners looking
at Western expressions and that would
reverse if Westerners has a look at
non-western expressions so there's
definitely a degree of cultural
influences on the recognition of these
expressions as well it's partly innate
and universal and there's a there's a
cultural overlay as well this is a joke
shoot you've got not only the wrong
planet but you got the wrong solar
system you mean a wrong planet I can
stand by the wrong solar system and you
can tell with just a little information
that this is a sheepish smile of
embarrassment and this is a little bit
of the body expression of you know a
little bit of arsonists
worked okay but here you know here's an
isolated preliterate tribe in New Guinea
and that smile looks like the smile of
any kid you ever saw it that's sadness
the sadness of any kid you ever saw a
little bit of a disgust and so people
build up a model something like there's
things in the environment that happen
that drives some sort of a facial effect
program your muscles in your face move
to express over six or so or different
kinds of feelings cultural rules about
what what should you show what should
you not show and different cultures or
some faces expressions are more
appreciated than others and finally all
of that moves into the facial expression
you make so now second question we have
so we see you think to a first
approximation you know shion's at least
as far as we can tell our pretty
universal
but there's cultural and learn to
expects pieces as well do emotions have
unique physiological signors could we
tell from your physiology what you're
feeling and there was a lot of hope that
this would work as we intuitively
emotions differ from one another we our
body feels different as we go from one
emotion to another and we use language
words like she got hot and bothered you
make my blood boil he's just letting off
steam all these are you know there's
different physiologies go with different
feelings and so people hope they could
make decision trees like this
let's measure your heart rate high or
low well if it's high then we get your
skin temperature and then we can tell if
you're angry or if you're sad that you
could make a decision tree by looking at
peripheral measures of physiology but it
never worked it was it's never been
strongly discriminating people have not
been able to have a you know
physiological fingerprint for the
emotion that you feel that's reasonably
accurate it's yeah
for instance put the measuring chemical
concentration it's possible yeah here's
a very good question here they're
measuring peripheral Physiology or
autonomic systems skin temperature heart
rate could there be other things like
chemicals right so I'd say yes but we
just don't know them well enough right
well could you have brain measures that
ultimately would be sophisticated enough
I can tell you that brain metrics are
not that good at that now okay but could
they be someday yes
so yes it's the specific measures that
we have you know our really deep
question will be at some level you know
when you're fearful and I'm fearful how
identical will those be right depending
on our cultural background depending on
situations we've experienced you know we
can both say we can both agree we're
scared of something but it could be
pretty different right okay so it's a
really deep question right when you know
at in the end how close are these things
from one person to another now at least
a speculative is why we have emotions
and you know sometimes obviously it's
help sometimes people think it's
increasing all functions win than us
we're organizing ourselves what's our
basic feeling are we basically happy or
sad about something or fearful of
something so that we use that feeling as
a source of information to sort of pull
ourselves to say like this is basically
where on my act it's a source of
information for me and it can tell me
what behavior makes sense to do in this
context and then from one person to
another interpersonally what does that
person feel what am i signal into that
person so here's an experiment and I'll
show you just a brief youtube video on
this because I think it's really cute
but it's almost a life and death
experiment although no infants was
harmed in the making of this experiment
okay so so what they do is this is a
visual cliff so they have a infant is
put on this a very tiny baby here it's
Plex hard Plexiglas there is no danger
to the baby okay but that there is a
drop here and a drop here now this is a
baby approaches this you know they're
not used to the idea of Plexiglas even
you and I would be pretty worried about
that okay if it was on a larger scale
right we want to be pretty sure about
the strength of that Plexiglas but the
infant's eyes they're approaching what
they call a visual
on the other side I'll show you the film
in a moment is a mother and the mother
can either be showing a positive
expression or a negative expression and
look what happens to the infant's in
this perilous situation where they see a
drop you know that's you know pretty big
okay and how much they trust their
mothers expression to know what to do so
if the mother is looking happy like it's
okay this is going to be great we're
having a lot of fun 3/4 of the time the
infant goes for it if the mother looks
scary never okay they're making kind of
a dangerous decision entirely on the
facial expression of the mother and
their trust that the mother knows the
right thing to do and is giving them the
right advice
so it's me you know sometimes you know
everything said college you can just
seem like oh it's just another thing but
facial expressions are an unbelievable
powerful way that we communicate with
one other um so here's an extremely
clever experiment from Adam Anderson
night you know who happened to be a
postdoctoral fellow in my lab but he did
this completely independently which is
this here's the question so okay we have
some different expressions and you could
say well are they completely random as
to what the actual expression is we
haven't even asked us see like why does
a smile go one way in a frown go or the
way does it mean anything or they just
arbitrary signals of different emotions
that have evolved over time and he's
almost the first person I know he even
asked this question I mean and he looked
at two emotions that we'll come back to
in just a little bit fear and disgust
okay uh and he thought well look it's
kind of interesting what fear and
disgust do for example fear your eyes
get bigger disgust think about something
really think about like something really
stinky okay yeah you close your eyes you
sort of scrunch up your nose here look
at this right and he looked at me he
looked at and measured how airflow
patterns and different things happen
when you go into those expressions okay
non-arbitrary properties of an
expression right and then he did
psychological expressions he got people
to get into these expressions and he
found that if they were in a fearful
expression that they would feel like
they had a wider field of view and if
it's discussed a smaller I think about
this for a moment when it's fearful do
you want to feel like you know want to
know what's going on around you right or
do you want to think that sit back and
think about you know stuff where do you
want to sit like oh oh right where do I
run what's going on when you go into
some disgusting situation you you know
do you want to really look around a lot
or are you kind of happy to find some
way out of it right okay same thing with
your nose here's the air velocity that's
passing through your nose when you're
fearful and when you're disgusted now
you don't you don't even think about
that right whoo
thinking like I'm controlling my air
velocity right but why do you think you
might want to really sample your
environment when you feel danger
visually you know in an olfactory way
why do you think you won't want to
sample what you want to know what's
going on you want the information as
fast as possible do I run do i duck what
do i do do I fight flee you know what do
I do I have moments to decide because
I'm in danger right if you're if you're
if you're in a discussed situation are
you interested typically in exploring
the olfactory environment in as much
detail as you can right okay usually not
right okay so it's kind of interesting
so the very first time I know this very
clever ask do where do these expressions
come from them well maybe they tend to a
certain extent to exaggerate or diminish
forms of sensory input that are relevant
for the emotion so for the last a little
bit I'm going to talk about for a little
while G what we know about the brain
basis of some emotions we already talked
about the idea that the amygdala plays a
special role in fear and I'll show you a
couple of different ways in which that's
true so this is just sitting in front of
the hippocampus one on the left one on
the right the core elements of your
limbic system here is viewed from the
side the amygdala here's here's the
actual amygdala from a post-mortem brain
and there's another whole level of
analysis that animal researchers do that
we can't touch today which is the
amygdala itself it's made out of bundles
of neurons called nuclei very distinct
ones that have different roles different
inputs different outputs and an animal
research where you can selectively in
you know influence one or the other you
can see they have quite different
specific roles in humans we don't have
that position of controls so we sort of
it have some clumped average statements
about the amygdala but really we're
mixing together a few functions so you
already saw this picture that animals
that mice or rats that have an amygdala
removed lose the fear they out of half
of a cat in primate studies they found
that if they have amygdala lesions the
loss of thread appreciation impairs
social fitness the animals that don't
know what they ought to be afraid of get
into big trouble that they lose or their
position and dominance hierarchies you
may know
primate groups tend to have dominant
hierarchies a sort of alpha male and so
on they slide down that if they lesion
the dominant male the alpha male the
male who wins all the fights and
controls the group the animal that
animal fall down the hierarchy and
become subordinate and in the wild
they've shown that if they do lesions
and return the animal to social
situation they get rejected by the other
animals because the other animals feel
there's something weird about the
animals and they're often isolated and
they get to early death because the
other animals are not helping them or
supporting them so you know very
important for learning what's dangerous
here's an experiment with rhesus monkeys
lesion at two weeks as infants returned
to their mothers and tested at eight
weeks and here's an example of something
so this is if you show an animal a novel
object and this is how often they
respond to it young animals will will
often not explore it because they go I
don't know that could be dangerous right
there they're waiting for their mother's
expression right here's the other
animals with the amygdala lesions
they'll explore it in a sense they're
fearless but that's probably not you
know an ideal thing to do when you're
infants exploring the world or they'll
put food near food only or food next to
a play snake okay snakes are dangerous
for monkeys they usually don't want to
figure out at this age you know is it a
play monkey it's a play snake or a real
snake they just say I don't really need
to eat that okay so everybody likes the
food put the snake next to it and the
control animals go no I don't think so
alright basically the amygdala ones you
know what's for dinner right and the
answer is if it's a real snake you're
for dinner right okay so they lose the
fear of things that ought to have fear
of if they have this they lose the
things fear of unknown things fear of
things they ought to be afraid of so the
amygdala place is really important role
fear sometimes is maybe the best
understood in motion in terms of brain
processes and maybe the most studied
partly because we've had some success in
understanding what's going on and partly
because fear is that maybe the emotion
that's most people think is closest to
survival you fear what kills you you
fear what pains you that's a very
powerful emotion for survival and safety
um
you can do fear conditioning we talked
about conditioning before and you know
all species from humans to primates
other mammals fruit flies you can do all
of them have to a first approximation
similar fear conditioning it's as if you
know if you're alive you have to fear
things that are scary and dangerous so
people have done fear conditioning
experiments and now you know this very
well you know you met your tone that's
not scary at first if you put it with
something that you don't like like a
foot shock you get fearful to the tone
and what people have discovered kind of
remarkably is that you can make lesions
in many parts of the brain and you don't
affect that learned fearfulness to the
tone but if you make a damage in the
part of the amygdala you abolish that
learning these animals fail to learn the
signal of something that is coming up to
be painful and dangerous you can even
make large lesions in the cortex that
doesn't affect anything and these
animals with the amygdala lesions they
have an intact unconditioned response
when they get the shock they jump like
the other animals they don't like it ok
it's not that they can't feel pain they
can't learn that the tone predicts the
painful stimulus they can't learn the
warning signal of danger there's very
few patients with amygdala injuries only
but there's a few so here's a patient
SMS with study by demas illness
colleagues this is where the amygdala
oughta be it's a developmental disorder
where this is calcified very early in
development it's not an adult lesion but
it seems to be fairly amygdala specific
and people have done a couple of
experiments with these patients too and
it's a serve guided our understanding of
what the amygdala does in you and I so
here's one example where they did
conditioning again in this case they
didn't use shocks they used a super-loud
boat horn okay that's pretty noxious to
people people don't like it and they
preceded that with something gentle that
warned you it was coming so here's
here's the initial response and then out
and then here's the important thing with
humans of course you can well let me
just say they don't mad they managed a
skin response to a galvanic skin
response to the bad tones so here's the
conditioned stimulus
you know the response to the to the boat
horns in the conditioning that what
predicts about horns here's the part
here's the response to the to the
baseline and here's the performance of
patients with amnesia who have the
amygdala spare or controls I'm sorry who
both can tell you they're responding
selectively to the scariest tones and
also remember perfectly well when you at
the end of the testing you session go
what went on and they say oh yeah well
when I got one signal I got a horrible
boat horn when I heard the other signal
I got nothing okay it's easy right okay
you do that for half an hour when you
get one visual signal that means boat
horn coming up one visual signal nothing
coming up if you have patients who have
mental lesions the galvanic skin
response doesn't happen even though they
tell you perfectly well afterwards what
happened so they know just like
everybody else that they got a certain
signal that went with a noxious boat
horn but their body is not learning that
Association if a patient has hippocampal
damage their body learns that
Association but they don't remember it
afterwards consciously so you can
separate at two kinds of learning a
hippocampal dependent learning of the
facts of the session and then the MiG
doula dependent learning which is a
bodily response to learning that
something is dangerous and unpleasant
now we often learn things like the
visual cliff without having to have a
boat horn and practice right if somebody
tells you that something is dangerous or
you figure out that something is
dangerous you don't have to go through a
terrible experience to pretty much
decide you're not going to do it so
here's an experiment that was a aimed at
showing you that so what people were
showing there's a funny human subjects
wrinkle to this I'll just tell you this
occurred at Yale where they had a blue
square came on that means safe you can
just relax nothing bad is going to
happen but when the yellow square comes
on get ready you might get a somewhat
unpleasant shock okay but they never
give them a shock so there's no you're
not learning that well you just you just
factually learn that something as safe
and something that's dangerous and
here's the amygdala response to the
scary one to a neutral situation and
the one where you know uh I'm safe okay
so you never got the shock you never got
the shock you were just told about the
shock you didn't have to get it but
you're a human you can figure this out
and your amygdala is going you know I
can just figure out that's dangerous
that's baseline and that's not that's
the absence of danger positive safety
okay
and be Li are be hilariously I think
said that oh but you're deceiving the
people because you tell them they were
going to might get a shock and they
never got a shock so you have to give
them one shock at the end of the
experiment so there's an the dutifully
the experimenters gave them one shock
after the experiment was over so they
were honest because during the
experiment as they measured the brain
activation in the amygdala responding to
the threat of pain without any pain
being associated right we're smart we
can learn something as dangerous just by
thinking it through it engages the same
part of the brain that learns by actual
painful experience now how about memory
so here's the way this study was done
people viewed a slide story with an
emotional middle section so an example
would be this parents are home having
breakfast with a kid you know parents go
to work kid walks to school kind of
tragically but these are all slides
again nobody was injured a child is hit
by a car something high arousing happens
in the middle of story everybody runs to
the hospital the kid is okay when people
ask a week later or something like that
I think three weeks a week later tell me
about the stories I told you last week
there's a number of stories people have
best memory for the part where something
highly arousing happen like the child
was hit by a car that makes sense right
kid having breakfast huh you know cute
okay huh car accident with a kid you're
aroused and you remember that better so
emotion is amplifying memory the
patients with the amygdala lesions don't
have that memory bump based on emotion
the emotion is not enhancing their
memory and you can imagine that there's
a pretty good reason for emotions to
enhance memory right if something is
fearful delightful horribly disgusting
those are all good reasons to remember
you know let's do that again if it's
great let's avoid
if it's terrible right okay I mean it's
a good idea for emotions to drive memory
formation and in your brain and mind
it appears the amygdala has this role of
transforming emotions into memories now
we also talked about six facial
expressions and I showed you this before
the same patients have trouble in
recognizing fearful facial expression so
kind of the amygdala in so many
different ways learning memory
perception of faces seems to play this
huge role in fear and kind of
interestingly because you might have the
intuition and this you know a lot of
this came from Freud you know that a lot
of our emotions are happening kind of
under our conscious awareness okay
we almost discover them after like why
am i angry at this person or why am I so
happy we have to think it through almost
if you show subliminal fearful faces
versus happy faces subliminally
presented so people can't tell you what
the face that expression was still they
turn on the amygdala so unconscious
perception of a fearful face engages the
amygdala you don't have to go through
consciousness cortical blindness we
talked about that early in the course
where you're blind in one visual field
and yet individual patients a couple of
them with cortical blindness if they
were shown a fearful stimulus in the
cortically blind field still turned on
in the cortically blind field the
amygdala for a fearful face versus a
happy face which indicates that a non
conscious subcortical pathway that
doesn't intersect with a conscious
thought or cortex is sending information
from your eyes to your amygdala okay a
different pathway and people have
speculated that you know maybe again
because fear is survival in danger we
might have a superhighway of information
that sends dangerous information
immediately to amygdala it doesn't wait
for you to think a lot so to speak in
your cortex boom yeah Danger Danger
Danger even before you process the rest
of the situation
so we talked about fear and the threat
in the amygdalae just say a word about
disgust people think that maybe a reason
you know there's many reasons things we
can be disgusted at or about but that
may be in terms of evolution it might
have been a pretty good signal for
contaminated food food that makes you
sick right things to avoid it makes you
sick and it turns out another part of
the brain called the insula is um pretty
important for that so here's the
amygdala left and right here's the
insula that you have left and right in
purple light in purple and again just
like with the amygdala patients with
lesions of the insula don't recognize
facial expressions and imaging wise if
you see a disgusted face that turns on
that part of the brain as well so those
are - those are the best understood
brain pieces of emotion by far so now
those are patient things so let me turn
for a moment now lastly to a few imaging
studies of typical people and about in
some topics on emotion so here's the
terrible pictures from 9/11 the horror
of the moment and we always imagine
we'll remember and we were talked a
little bit about this in flashbulb
memories emotionally things correctly
for a long time the horror of that
moment the King went on I shall never
forget this is Lewis Carroll through the
looking-glass you will though the Queen
said if you don't make a Memorandum of
it and now you know that Lewis Carroll
was talking about the amygdala right
yeah you didn't know that before but you
know that now because if the amygdala
isn't there the emotional intensity
doesn't make the memory more permanent
or more powerful so Larry Cahill UC
Irvine did the first brain study on this
topic and what he did is he showed
people students while they were getting
PET scanning positron emission
tomography on films short films that
were either powerfully emotional or
neutral and then he brought them back
three weeks later and here's what he
found the more activation there was in
the amygdala each square here is a
different person the more they
remembered the emotional stuff but it
didn't matter from neutral things
the amygdala seems unimportant for
neutral information but the more it was
engaged the more they remembered
emotional information so this is sort of
evidence in the typical human mind of a
relationship between the amygdala
and emotional memories so here's an
experiment actually that we did at
Stanford where we show people stimuli
that we're either neutral somewhat
negative and now I'm going to show you
something that's very negative if you
don't want to look close your eyes for a
moment close your eyes there we go
very negative okay sorry all right it
turns out if we don't show you something
that negative it's hard to get your
brain pumped up this is a it doesn't
have to be all these that's sad but it
has to be pretty intense okay so we show
you things like this and we record you a
brain response for each of those and
here's what we do we ask you to tell us
how bad is this so the baby picture was
bad right okay for most people we wait
three weeks pretty long time and then we
test your memory for the scenes from
before they would test your memory three
weeks later pretty long time and here's
what we see it two things so one in the
left amygdala in this study here's what
you rated is terrible pretty bad
somewhat bad in neutral so the amygdala
is responding to your subjective sense
of terribleness now you know we're
really looking at arousal negativity we
didn't see posit we didn't look at
positive ones I can tell you in other
studies here's a trick in research I'm
going to tell you now I don't have a
couple more slides but we tell you a
little bit about insider things on
imaging just so you understand imaging
as as human and fallible a form of
research is anything which you might
suspect anyway so so you know so you
know we've showed these things and we
got these responses okay so that's going
with your subjective sense of how bad
films are and then when we tested
people's memory what we also found was
that memory was best when we got the
biggest amygdala response so that's just
like you heard before okay
so that all seemed fine to the line ones
that you know lined up with the prior
result but here was the slight surprise
and a thing that followed and they still
gets cited fairly often it's the
research that I've been affiliated with
guess still cited most often in
newspapers and magazines okay so anyway
so this was a study you saw before and I
think I didn't emphasize to you was that
this was in the right amygdala in the
GEMA sphere doesn't really matter it
just happened to be that our study at
Stanford was in the left hemisphere this
is what we were getting the emotion
memory responses and so we were very
deep scientists okay
and we said what could be going on you
know why is Larry Cahill at UC Irvine
getting it in the left amygdala the more
active it is the more you would remember
emotional information and why are we
getting it in the right why's he getting
the right medal I'm getting left in the
glocca so we met we took a piece of
paper we wrote down the different things
that people had found though the story
was going to tell you about Stefan
Hammonds study so Stefan Hammond at
Emory did a study where he said okay all
this amygdala response to negative
things does it also respond to positive
things that's a good question right and
the answer is yes but it turns out in
many experiments it doesn't look that
way because you saw for those of you who
looked at horrible-looking baby picture
what would be an equal positive powerful
picture let's try this one everybody
agrees it's cute when there's little
children around a birthday cake okay
smile I see smiles all right all right
all right
powerful unless as your kid may be
powerful image powerful as the face of
the infant no okay so it's very hard to
get it's a really interesting thing it's
very hard to get positive stimuli that
are asked potent as negative stimuli
it's just you can get a million negative
stimuli from the internet it's very hard
to get very positive ones okay having
said that we said let's let's think
about the negative ones for the moment
so you know we at our studies with fMRI
pet pet ours were all with women and
these were all with men and you could go
well why did that happen okay it's good
that is half women half men you know
because these were positron emission
tomography these a that involves
injecting radioactive stuff into people
to do that kind of imaging and many IRB
say well let's not have women do it
because they could be unknowingly
pregnant they could be and we shouldn't
be giving radioactive stuff's just for
an experiment okay you could have
debates about that but that's what the
thought you know why not let the men get
their radioactive stuff okay we don't
really need them or so that and then so
when we did this study we said well
these were all with men it seems with
fairness we should do with women too you
know we just thought it seemed fair kind
you know we didn't have any big thought
about that and you know and again we
were getting left in mingle and they
were getting right amygdala pictures or
films different enough and this caught
our eye that we had done studies with
women we were getting left in the glad
they did it with men with right amygdala
so deep scientists that we were Larry
Cahill has said all tested you know men
and women and we said we'll test men and
women and here's what we found and these
are averages but one critical thing went
that we discovered we didn't know this
is that to the extent and these are
averages of course these are averages
that you compare men and women on
average women have better memory for
emotional life events faster production
of autobiographical to memories to cues
more accurate and dating memory so these
dating studies are pretty useful because
you never know how accurate a person is
when they have a memory for something
whether they do in the dating studies is
they have people who are dating keep
Diaries for example in the fall semester
okay and presumably those are reasonably
accurate they're filling them in every
day and then you know things happen over
the holidays and some people remain
dating and some don't right so you go
back to them in March and you go in your
fall when the two of you were going out
you know tell us about what you did in
November and you know and they can say
who's more accurate okay and they have
almost a virtual record because they
have the responses that the men and the
women put down that day and on average
is their average the women were more
accurate and why score higher than
husbands on vividness of memories our
first date last vacation recent argument
okay so these are all averages there's
lots of overlap but on average is that
way and so Larry Cahill went and did
this thing and sure enough again as he
found before for men the more they turn
on the right amygdala the more certain
they were to remember negative films and
from women the more they turned on the
left amygdala the more certain they
would remember negative films on average
now I think to know is on average again
when you have people rate the kinds of
pictures we use how do you think was
your here it is this is one example
where your stereotype guesses probably
play out for the averages who rates this
is more scary or who says it's more
scary men or women okay
so what positive or negative I just
actually is for positive or negative so
here's a women not finding this a
particularly on average and there's a
range of responses not finding this
particularly a positive picture here's
men going pretty cool you don't wear
that with what DVD does that come from
okay so you know people are always
asking like you know what does this
really mean and then just knowing they
have to do this or whatever the question
you're right now who knows okay there's
no answer to this about whether it's
social things or biology it's probably
certainly social things are a big part
of the story um when we have people rate
the pictures in the scanner here's the
women rating here's the worst pictures
and look at them and they're less
willing to rate these pictures as bad
against psychologists you know who see
these data say well maybe the men think
you're never supposed to rate them as
bad because you know because we're tough
guys and nothing so bad right I mean I
don't know who knows okay but this is
the ratings now if we look at the
activation of men and women on the left
as they rate them the worse they rate it
the more intense they find it the more
they turn on their left amygdala so at
the moment they're rating them men and
women look very similar but when we
related to their memory two things
happen first the women did have superior
memory to the men these were Stanford
undergraduates probably not that
dissimilar on average to the people in
this room and quite strikingly as you
saw it
activation the right hemisphere
predicted memory and men and the left
hemisphere for women so I know there's
been a lot of right and left but here's
the here we think was the message and
you know it's kind of stood the test of
time a little bit on average so what you
see here is the part of the left
amygdala turn-on for women as they're
rating it more intense than more active
in relation to whether they form a
long-term memory the more active the
more likely to remember it and kind of
the physical overlap of the two in men
more active on in that amygdala on the
left
during the rating but doesn't seem to be
involved in memory formation in the
hippocampus again overlap overlap
overlap no apparent overlap and the men
so what happens literally in the brain I
mean literally as far as we can measure
it in women on average there was more
overlap between the parts of the brain
engaged as you evaluate something and
the parts of the brain that make the
memory of that and in men is on average
it was as if here's my emotional rating
on the right and here's what I'm going
to remember on the left kind of a
separation of those processes in the
most simple sense
now here's a huge question does this
brain imaging study you know tell us
anything about whether this is in the
genes of boys and girls as they're born
or a consequence of socialization or
both it's incredibly intuitive for
people to think that if you see it in
the brain it's hardwired and genetic or
hormonal or something okay brain imaging
data never tells you that it never tells
you that it just tells you by this age
this is what's going on and you don't
have to know much psychology to know
that we're all hugely influenced to
varying degrees but we're all hugely
influenced by social influences and what
it is to be a male or female in our
families and our cultures and our
societies whether something's in your
genes or in your culture it shows up in
your brain right okay and we can't tell
those two things apart
you know is this anything to do with how
we're born is this anything to do with
how Hollywood pitches you know movies
that are about video game battles versus
flick was it chick flicks is yeah and
how you know they're how they're
pitching that and trying to tell us
we're supposed to like something you
know who knows we can't tell if it's
social or JEDEC at all
you